als luca über eine liebens zuschauer wir
schauen uns heute mal wieder ebay
kleinanzeigen fiel dann bereits vor zwei
wochen haben wir uns ja schon ebay fels
angeschaut
rola fast mehr ja da war wirklich
intelligenz pur am start allerdings
würde ich sagen fangen wir jetzt auch
direkt an mit dem ersten ebay fail also
wer mit playmobil-figuren unter arsch
playmobil
der nächste ebay fall den wir haben ist
das hier das ist ein meerschweinchen
meerschweinchen hassen stahl ich glaube
er mein meerschweinchen hasenstall aber
kann natürlich auch sein dass
meerschweinchen prinzipiell stahl hassen
die haben wir ein mario klotz levels
king dem battle das ist ein sehr neues
spiel tatsächlich für die switch ohne
jetzigen die werbung machen zu wollen
oder so hier steht allerdings mario plus
rapids kondomen kondom battle ja sie
streiten sich darum wer das kondom
kriegt der verkauft jemand sein call of
duty 4 modern warfare spiel für die
playstation 3
der schrei nach einem call of duty
allerdings zu einem ebay kleinanzeigen
felber dem mal wieder ein kleiner text
runter steht und zwar verkaufte jemand
seinen schmatzenden namenstag
wie kommt man denn auf so ne scheiße ich
verschenke meinen hamster es macht mich
einfach wahnsinnig dass er seine schnute
beim kauen nicht superagent nicht so
ganz stumpf trockene unten steht einfach
sein name ist paul
ich meine wer hätte nicht gern so ein
schmatzen dem namen star robin fix
rubbellos erhöhte gewinnchance verkauft
dort jemand für 500 euro seien rubbellos
dass das ist doch schon auf gerubbelt
aber wir schauen uns mal den text an ich
verkaufe ein rudel fix los mit einem
maximalen gewinn von 25.000 euro zwei
von sechs feldern sind schon frei noch
einmal 25.000 euro und du hast den
hauptgewinn los schnapp dir ja geil
playstation 4 zu verschenken
er verschenkt die einfach haben einen
sohn die versetzung in die realschule
nicht geschafft hat verschenke ich das
elende stück hier ich habe das geschrei
beim spielen satt es reicht die scheiß
konsole muss weg alles was auf dem bild
zu sehen ist kann mit alter das war bei
mir zu den schulzeiten allerdings
ähnlich und zwar weil ich halt riesiger
you can also von der serie auf rtl 2 und
ich wollte das immer gucken und meine
eltern einfach gesagt hey du darfst du
so viel am tag gucken und dann eine gute
noten schreibt selbst eine folge merck
und wenn nicht dann darfst du gar nicht
mehr gucken und glaubt mir
in zeiten wo man nicht alles auf abruf
im internet gucken konnte sondern
wirklich eine geregelte zeit im
fernsehen
[Applaus]
das wollte man gucken und deswegen hat
man sich dann auch angestrengt in der
schule und trotzdem bin ich jetzt und
spaß geworden als nächstes verkauft
jemand auf ebay seine airports bruch
s wie neu alle klar super sound mega
bass kabel leider abgerissen jetzt
benutzbar als airports auf sonne idee
musst du halt wirklich erstmal kommen
haare schneiden
da fehlt auch ein
packen wir verkauft jemand psp happy
potter käppi potter wieder fertig gesagt
nicht so glücklich aus hosted ackermann
keine ahnung was das hier ist kaká man
auf klo sehr düster war glaube ich
schreiben ich dachte das ist eine
dienstleistung die wir verkauft so wenn
man das kaufen 50 euro dann postet der
interkama aber es geht tatsächlich um
dieses poster machen weiter mit jemanden
der ein plüschtier verkauft und zwar
eine giraffe schreibt allerdings drunter
schildkröte 15 euro verhandelbar höhe 17
cm knopf und vorne fehlt samt sehr guter
zustand privatverkauf ohne garantie und
kein umtausch keine ahnung über dir zu
hause schildkröten außen aber das hier
ist in meinen augen eher nen hund
aquarium und pumpe punkt hier verkauft
jemand einen halt sehr ist es ein
kleiner ich glaub das ist ein roma oder
irgendwie sowas hier unten steht
aquarium mit kratze
mit kratze ein bis zwei dazu bodengrund
sind dabei wer kennt sie nicht die
kratzen
als nächstes verkauft hier jemand sich
selbst und zwar kein mensch sondern ein
döner der sucht nämlich einen job als
döner ich frag mich echt was das für
mini götter sein müssen die auf solche
ideen kommen geiles bild für wohnungs
zimmer mit rahmen 1300 euro gutes bild
für wohnungs zimmer rahmen kann nicht
geändert werden ist mit schrauben rein
geklebt mit schrauben rein geklebt und
dann auch noch rahmen und hier schreibt
der wohnungstür richtig aber unten
schreibt es dann wieder falsch ist aber
echt ein geiles bild eine fette katze
eine banane könnte ich mir auch in
meinem wohnzimmer vorstellen katze zu
verschenken
mit einer katzenkrankenversicherung kann
man hier noch bis zum 9 50 sparen es ist
eine hauskatze sich älter als acht
wochen und der text darunter ist ist
verschmust houben rein
tuben rein also ist und ich war drei
bücher von shakespeare of grey
ja wir kennen die nicht william
shakespeare der erfinder von shakespeare
auf greig verkaufe rutsche für 1 dünnen
hamster verkaufte diese rutsche für
hamster mein hamster kämpfte mit
gewichtsproblemen seit den feiertagen
und passt deshalb nicht mehr in die
rutsche ich weder bild jetzt erst
richtig jeder saison ein scheiß ich weiß
nicht was auf ebay kleider zeigen immer
los ist mit den hamstern
in der letzten folge hatten wir schon
ein zwei hamster dabei und heute auch
schon wieder zwei beziehungsweise hier
wieder nicht der hamster verkauft
sondern lediglich die rutsche steht hier
unten ja auch noch mal es wird nur die
rutsche verkauft damit mein hamster
nicht täglich an seine mutter hüften der
integriert tausche auch gegen einen
hamster hantelbank ehre der villa doch
dass ein hamster ein bisschen trainieren
geht ohne zu wackeln mein gott das ist
doch nicht wahr
das traurige ist dass darauf
wahrscheinlich wirklich sogar noch
einige leute auf ebay einfallen würden
also kein scheiß das gute drohne ohne
werden bedienung
man schmeißt das ding wahrscheinlich
dann einfach hier ist einfach ein haus
abgebildet
bauernhof für 110.000 euro pro monat ich
dachte erst dass hier irgendwie diese
schneide der verkauf werden die da
irgendwie liegen
aber dann habe ich halt wirklich lesen
bauernhof ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
wo das überhaupt irgendwie bauernhof
sein sollen als nächstes verkaufte
jemand sein handy und zwar steht hier in
dem titel galaxy s 6 zu zeigen
ich habe hier s6 galaxy und bin sehr
zufrieden damit und ich will es nicht
verkaufen zeige ich euch nur dass sich
ein handy einfach mal angeben auf gb das
nächste bild dass jule hier für mich
ausgesucht hat ich sehe die sache
übrigens nicht vorher ich sehe die
gerade wirklich zum ersten mal weil juli
medien ein schnittprogramm auch einzieht
das bild hier ist auf jeden fall nicht
aus ebay sondern aus einer
facebook-gruppe und zwar kleinanzeigen
aachen jülich düren erft stadt
euskirchen also in köln direkt nebenan
das ist nämlich thorsten 7 euro und
ach sein denn toaster heißt thorsten
einstiges pferd zu verkaufen oder tausch
für 1500 euro um einen gott okay das
pferd ist echt ein bisschen dick
verkaufe 1 fährt weil ich nun doch
lieber ein auto möchte wenn es kalt
draußen ist rasse und alter kann ich
nicht sagen hat aber zb es es hört auf
den namen dicke bäume und schwitzt viel
tausch gegen auto rücktausch im sommer
möglich aber wer die so was einfallen
lässt er hat ihn glücklich der hat so
einen humor grad das ist unfassbar als
nächstes verkauft jemand seinem glas
tisch bausatz und zwar so aus jetzt
nicht da es wie bei ikea muss man sich
dann selbst zusammenbauen lkws und bot
und ski-ass
ich glaube mein lkws boot und chats kino
wie das hier zu beurteilen ist gute zu
stammen geil alter wie sofort zuschlagen
ja punkt kabel zum irgendwo rein stecken
geil
als nächstes verkaufte jemand eine
ohrfeige zum abholen der preis ist
verhandelbar
und die nachfrage ist hoch auch gerne
als geschenk für freunde respekt
wirklich an den menschen die der so
einen humor hat uns sowas einfach in
ebay stellte allerdings nur doch schon
zu dem letzten beitrag hier auf ebay
kleinanzeigen und zwar original
handtasche von luisa viotti
ja luisa viotti
anders stelle sich das heutige bietet
allerdings auch beenden meiner lieben
zuschauer ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
der erste teil ebay kleinanzeigen mit
luca kam ja mega mega mega mäßig gut bei
euch an ich weiß dass einige andere
youtuber auch serien haben in denen sie
ebay kleinanzeigen vorstellen allerdings
zins hat ebay kleinanzeigen und davon
gibt es millionenfach und daher hoffe
ich dass euch das heutige video hier
gefallen hat es getan hat würde ich mich
sehr gerne bei einem daumen hoch unter
dem video freund und schreibt mir bitte
in die kommentare
ob ich so was eventuell in der woche
noch mal hoch laden soll rochat
es gibt tausende ebay kleinanzeigen fans
das ist unfassbar die dummheit ist
wirklich nicht zu stoppen
[Musik]